so madam X she is all these things but
one thing we didn't expect madam XP was
a soccer mom that that just you know I
think genuinely people were kind of like
she's done what now yeah it was
surprising that you upped sticks and
moved to Elizabeth yes I surprised
myself yeah yeah because you post things
online you see that David is really good
at the piano and dances door thank God I
wish she wanted to be a singer me it was
a disappointment easier for me yeah was
it a disappointment that he chose sport
over music um I can't say it's a
disappointment that's not fair I just
it's a challenge can you focus on an
entire anything right now
like if you watch if you watched it if
you want to get the football wait Mike
what's up medication hasn't kicked in
yet I'm sorry can you focus if you've
got a CEO of a football game can you can
you watch the whole thing I only watch
when my son's playing okay if truth is
told I mean if he doesn't have the ball
you look away he's sitting on the bench
I'm on my phone
[Music]